i don't know if you've also seen tyson
talk about
he was on rogan recently he was talking
about
he was trying to psychoanalyze himself
about
why he enjoys violence so much i mean he
called it
orgasmic i don't know have you seen that
clip
i haven't okay we're playing it because
i can
i need to because trump also retweeted
it which is hilarious i don't know how
to contextualize yeah that's something
that our president
retweeted the clip of uh
let's say off tyson saying that's just
maybe he's just doing
like they're not it's like i'm gonna
throw him a curveball no one's gonna
have any idea what that is
but yeah he did no explanation just here
you go there you go
well i think that's kind of like what
you're describing it's like if i give
you an answer it has to be a good one
better to just let your imagination run
exactly
yeah he's yeah he's like the kubrick of
our time
you know what's really interesting that
sometimes um
periodic it's not real but sometimes i
struggle with the fact that while
there's a possibility i can really hurt
somebody
like you don't want to hurt them
what do you mean but you struggle
struggle with the possibility that you
could hurt them
that is sometimes it's orgasmic
sometimes
yeah like some fights like particularly
like
tyro biggs or someone that you had
problems with
someone that you joe's not getting you
had animosity towards
so when you finally get your hands on
them hey um
what does it mean um when fighting gets
gets you erect what does that mean it's
a good question
means you're getting excited yeah so
that that's going through your mind
right now well that's how i get when i
was a kid and i you know sometimes
i get to twinkle the twinkle yeah well
that's what i'm saying is like you
reached a state as a human being as a
champion
as a ferocious fighter you reached a
state of of
ability and of accomplishment that very
few humans will ever
ever touch and feel that's why i'm
asking you
when you're running when you're hitting
the bag when that heart's beating again
and that you know who you are
you're mike [ __ ] tyson so when
you're doing all this [ __ ] again you're
still mike tyson
those thoughts have got to be burning
inside you again
it's gotta be pretty wild i don't know
it's um it's wild but um
i believe it's um it's rightfully so to
be that way and i just know how to
um i don't think i i'm masturbating how
to deal with it
i don't let it overwhelm me i mean he
goes on to try to
they don't ever like joe doesn't
bite well the interesting thing about
that
conversation is mike was trying to
figure himself out
yeah like he's trying on the spot like
why do i feel this way
to me it was like to me it's so real
and honest to uh to feel
like pleasure from hurting somebody
like that you rarely hear that
in this society it's like you rarely
like talk about like you feel pleasure
from
winning you feel pleasure from like
the relief of overcoming like
all the stress you have to go through
pleasure from
just like the the specifics of the fight
the techniques you use the
maybe overcoming being down a couple
rounds but like how often do you hear
somebody say
i just enjoyed he's not even saying
because i hate the opponent
he's saying like i enjoyed purely
the violence of it that's crazy
i mean i don't know it's honest
it made me ask like i wonder how many of
us are cognizant of that
let's say mike is uncommonly seemingly
uh
honest i think athletes make a full-time
job out of lying
you know i think people make a full
themselves perhaps too that's fair
i mean in some you tell yourself or you
tell others what you feel you need to or
maybe whether you
would even know what you feel you need
to but why should he not
i mean again did he did he run up and
just hit somebody that's
didn't sign up for this no they signed
it to be there
well that's the interesting thing about
dyson is there's that weird uh
like non-standard behavior i mean
like your fighting style is not standard
he's non-standard to another degree of
like
uh who else has that in jiu jitsu uh
polaris uh uh has this kind of
weirdness like what's what's
in there like there's a fear that
i think uh most opponents would have
because it's like it's no longer about
like it takes you out of the realm of
its
game it takes us back to the thing we're
talking about
like before is it strips away that like
several layers of ryan hall the the
podcast
uh guest ryan hall the jiu jitsu
instructor ryan hall
just a competitor it keeps going down to
a point where like
ryan hall the murderer of all things
that get in his way
that lies underneath all of it seemingly
like if we're
like in this society we put all that
aside but it makes you wonder
like now society's being tested in many
ways it makes you wonder like
what's underneath there well do we want
do we want the answer to that because i
guess it's what is it uh you seem paul
fiction you know the best character in
the movie and
in the best scene in the movie he's like
if my questions here if you're what he
called him my answers scare you she's
asking scary questions
you know and i guess uh you wonder i
mean all of us that's something that i
think it's funny
oh that's not okay i mean versus maybe
not appropriate
for situation x y or z but uh
what should make any of us think i mean
humanity is a different place now and
i'm not saying anything
crazy out there but it managed a
different place now than we were 5 000
years ago
where all of us are descended from
people who have killed things with their
teeth and fingernails in order to be
where we are
and whether it was in whether it was an
animal or was in conflict with another
person
i mean think about the chances of dying
by violence now are so
so slim at least in in most countries in
most places like shockingly small
thankfully but there was a period of
time like the most
period of time where dying by violence
was mostly how it went down
and i guess what would be facilitative
what would allow you to win
back to ender's game you know what
allows you
if you can't do that you are all you are
forever subject to people who can
and that's that's a real thing and
you know we're fortunate to find
ourselves in a situation where we don't
where other things matter but that is a
funny thing periodically where people
you'll see people like kind of drawing
at each other like in videos or out in
the world
that clearly neither of them expect this
to get serious like i'm just going to
yell at you you're going to yell at me
and it's like this weird larping thing
we're both going to go on our own
separate way all it takes is one person
be like well
i wasn't kidding yeah and it's like oh
you'll go to jail i'm like oh i know
you're going to go to the morgue and
it's that's but that can happen
like that like society i mean obviously
anyway you could jump across the table
and stab me in the eye
i mean i appreciate hope if you don't
and there will be consequences if you do
but not from
not from me from from the rest of
society will
potentially get you at a certain point
but you can decide to not play by the
rules
anytime you want and it's fascinating
that yeah that's
we've created rules based on which we
all behave but underneath there
you know there there's things that
doesn't
there's motivations and forces that
don't play by the rules
they're still there nature's metal is
under the surface
seriously and again i pull out my phone
and i'm basically saying like hey
i'm gonna you're gonna get caught yeah
but really i'm further antagonizing you
yeah
rightly wrongly you know what i mean
like and that that's an interesting
thing and i feel like just people need
to remember any of us need to remember
just for any reason just that's
that's one step away at all at all times
you ever i've had people say to me
before like oh i don't feel safe i'm
like you're not safe
i'll kill you before you get out of this
room nothing you do stop that nothing
i mean but don't worry you could do the
same to me which means i'm like oh thank
goodness can you imagine like how many
guns are there are in this country
like i mean everywhere i mean seriously
everywhere
but that's a heartening thought not the
other way because people usually freak
out and go oh my god gun violence gun
violence says gun violence is
like really not a serious issue in the
united states compared to what it could
be
because it means that i mean with the
amount of guns and the amount of
bullets that are out there that are in
circulation can you imagine if like
one in every thousand was used in anger
each day i mean
this would be a terrifying place to live
you couldn't go anywhere so i mean
although you could say hey this is more
than we'd like or xyz
it actually means that people are much
more reasonable insane than we're saying
then or then i then sometimes i might
and i might argue so i guess what i mean
is like oh man i walked to 7-eleven
and i didn't get stabbed i'm like oh
well that's good because not because i
protected myself with my karate
it's basically no one decided to run
over and stab me because i wasn't
protecting myself it's
like they stopped so i guess we're all
fortunate to live in a society that that
like you said nature being metal doesn't
become that big of an issue all the time
but it is funny when you get people in
the ring and you go hey let's peel back
from mr tyson many layers of that and
say hey now it's okay
and it's cool that i mean that's what
society is doing so i've
lived in harvard square for a while and
we
add extra layers of what safe means like
now there's a dis discourse about safe
spaces about like
ideas being violence or or like uh
you know yeah but ideas or
minor slights against your personality
being violence
but that's all like extra layers around
the nature's metal thing
that uh it's cool that's that's what
progress is but we can't forget that
like underneath it it's still
it's still the the thing that will
murder at the at the drop of a
in any at any moment if uh if aroused
one thing that i find funny though or
ironic maybe about the uh
the you know words of violence you know
offenses violence thing
is that of course that if that the
belief in that then
justifies my violence like my
and whether maybe maybe not physical
violence but my response to my
my aggressive response to things and i
guess like which again
regrets begets a further aggressive
response and like a you know kind of a
tit-for-tat sort of situation or or it
goes to like well there's ten of me and
there's one of you so we'll get you and
you can't do anything about it
but that's not morality that's that's
just saying that's might makes right
so i guess again you can understand why
people do it and there are certain there
is a progress aspect to it
but again i guess without proper
examination i'm effectively
with my 10 friends you know and and the
force of the law mike tysoning people
but not admitting to myself what i'm
doing and at least mike tyson again is
honest
you